[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast i am
very pleased to welcome nancy rommelman
author of the book to the bridge a true
story of motherhood
and murder and a reporter for reason
magazine who has recently spent
a great deal of time in my home city of
portland
reporting on the protests and riots and
other phenomena
welcome nancy i'm delighted to be here
thanks
so i should probably alert our audience
that you lived in portland for how many
years
15 years i lived there from 2004 until
uh
late 2019 so you and i barely overlapped
you saw the portland that existed before
and uh
i am now watching it turn into something
new and
you're coming out to report for a reason
and tell their audience what's going on
so what is going on in portland from
your perspective
what's going on in portland is something
that's been building well i think i
think the sort of protest
gene is built into portland it's been
there i guess since the 60s or 70s
you know whether it was you know uh
earth rights or don't eat animals or
whatever it is they're they're
they're a uh a city that likes to
protest um
they've sort of been building up a head
of steam
uh progressive values kind of steam for
the past i'd say since about 2015 you
and i i think have seen some of that
in action um then we had a little bit of
a weird depression in portland i noticed
when i was there in december a lot of
downtown was closed
i was like well it's kind of interesting
like it doesn't make people feel good
when the neighborhood's kind of insecure
right
then you had kovid what happens you know
the city closes down
kids are home uh people can't do
anything
george floyd was killed and the city
exploded
and it had been primed to explode and
the reasons were you know grief and
frustration
to begin with and i think now we're
seeing it
it morph into other things and gain
steam
which includes um trump sending the feds
in
um which includes let's abolish all
police
so we've got a bit of a of a movement
rolling
right now and gathering um adherence
as it rolls yeah i agree with that
although
i am increasingly reluctant to take
any of the things that we are simply
supposed to assume
about this and apply them in other words
i've seen so many
things slid in under the radar by virtue
of
um you know redefinition of words and
things that i'm
i'm very careful about things like grief
i'm not saying nobody was motivated by
grief but i have the sense that i was
not actually
watching anything that literally
lines up with what we understand grief
to be what it was was some kind of an
outpouring of emotion that surrounded a
death
and so grief was like the next nearest
concept
i would agree with that i would agree
not just in portland but in general
people
uh with various degrees of cognizance
will appropriate the pain of others um
to
animate whatever it is that they want to
do whether it's a personal thing like
someone wants to
you know pretend that they're in
terrible pain so you give them sympathy
or
you're part of a movement and you feel
more part of that movement when you
you've got that what are they called
collective effervescence right we're all
here experiencing
this thing at one time and i think that
is something that's
popular in portland uh you know whether
it's um you know the [ __ ] hats or
they're
they're marching for something else
they're the portlanders tend
to want to form a group
and be angry or euphoric or outraged
together well there's actually a a
biological
facet to this which is very well covered
in the book
behave by robert sapolsky and it has to
do
with oxytocin which many people take to
be the love
hormone but it turns out it's a great
deal more complex than that
because it is really the in-group
out-group
hormone and so it does accompany
for example the birth of a child a
mother will be flooded with oxytocin and
feel this incredible bond
to her child initially but it is also
a hormone that accompanies the
out-grouping of people that is to say
the demonization of people before you go
to war
with them for example and so one of the
things that is so
troubling about the phenomenon in
portland and all of the
other places that are are mirrored by it
is that there is this very intense sense
of camaraderie clearly among the
protesters and rioters but it is
accompanied by
a fervor and a willingness to demonize
anybody who doesn't say the right things
or
behave in you know exact alignment and
so
um that very same phenomenon that has
portland rioters burning down buildings
demonizing
um police demonizing uh
anybody who is not in agreement with
them could be
a force for our collective alignment
around problems that
confront all of us like covet for
example or
the corruption of our political
apparatus right but wouldn't that take a
certain amount of um
consideration and and less slogan
earring
wouldn't it take a little more being
thoughtful uh
then you know it's it's i i know one
thing that we've seen in the past couple
of weeks in portland
which i find extremely disturbing um are
the
groups and i and i've been with them
when they've done this when they've you
know sort of funneled into the streets
at midnight you know you've got 400
young people in
black militia wear and helmets and they
funnel into a street very quietly and
unlit residential street
and start shouting at the people uh
inside you know to wake up you know
literally
and metaphorically and you know when i
first was with them i thought oh do they
really you know
expect people to get up and start
marching with them and then i realized
that was incredibly naive of me
um it is a bit i know they're they're
not going to claim it's
it's a terror tactic but you know i
think it is
um but the i i've had two people one i
saw on video and one i i heard myself
say you know i'd like to be asleep
too but i'm out here every night
fighting for justice while you you know
sleep with your comfortable lives it's
like
well yeah well you don't have to be out
here
doing this and you certainly don't have
to be out here doing this
uh um and thinking that this is the way
you're going to create a better society
yeah i saw a clip i don't know if it was
part of the same
incident but um one of the protesters
was
seemed to me rationalizing to herself
she just happened to have
a megaphone in her hand so we got to
hear her thought process and
um she was you know basically convincing
herself that
she clearly deserved to be paid for
protesting you know
this even as she's waking up
her fellow you know citizens of portland
you know in what is absolutely a very
thinly veiled threat right
it's a threat you we need you to to join
our movement to add fuel to it
or else you know and at the same time
not only are they
confronting um citizens as
they sleep but they are making it
impossible for the police to do normal
policing
because the idea is everything will be
scrutinized and the least
generous interpretation will be put on
any action
by the police therefore the police are
hamstrung
well i have quite a lot to say about
this i mean first of all
uh you know black block which is sort of
the
a good number of the people that you
know meet in parks at night at eight
o'clock you don't know what park it's
going to be if you're a citizen unless
you're like
watching you know the certain groups
that announce it earlier in the day
and they have their little they get
together they do a little shield
practice and then they
they go out and they attack whatever
they're going to attack whether it's you
know the portland police union or the
ice headquarters or
a police station and they uh
they have and i i think you've probably
seen this uh they have
dozens and dozens of people running
around that says press
right little a little on their hat or on
their shirt now obviously as a
real press person i've never done that
in my entire life but they do this for
several reasons
one is because uh in portland you're not
allowed to interfere with the press the
press must be allowed to observe
but they also film incessantly first of
all they're of the filming generation
right everything is filmed
and then they edit it very carefully so
that you
see that they are always sort of
victimized by the police or you know by
a citizen that's yelling at them
meanwhile
um if you are just trying to film
because that's your job
uh they will just shout in your face
over and over and over you're not
allowed to film you're not allowed to
film it's like excuse me who uh
who in the world said this you could
tell me that but it's not true
i had my phone stolen i luckily got it
back
um because i was filming um but they are
creating the narrative that seeps out
into the media
uh one thing i noticed too that they do
um they they have these shields right
that they build and has the anarchist
system where it doesn't and they go out
and they
kind of like set up they're gonna
they're gonna defend themselves from the
police
but i don't think that's what it's about
at all it's all about getting the
picture
of the police that cuts through these
shields like a hot knife through butter
because these kids are
they are sort of ungainly for the most
part
and it's basically to get another shot
of them being
victimized by the brutal gestapo that
are the police that they are
out to uh get rid of uh
they're not doing a terribly bad job of
of making
uh the police look bad if you want to
believe their narrative
yeah i i agree and it's um it's actually
it's absolutely terrifying
to watch how the press handles what's
going on it doesn't make the least
effort to report what's actually taking
place in essence
what happens is um you know actually
there's a
have you seen a film i think it's called
a film unfinished
what it is is the nazis set out to
make a propaganda film in the warsaw
ghetto
and they never finished it and a modern
director
took the footage and um reassembled it
so you could see what the nazis were up
to right
and it was like take after take
of some situation that made the jews in
the ghetto
look awful but it was like they would do
the same scene
you know 20 times right with the intent
to get the one that looked worse
and that the only thing you needed to
see in order to understand what was
really going on was that you know the 20
takes
you know where it was like action you
know um
and so this is it has the same flavor
where it's like okay
you're going to have hour after hour of
interaction
between the police and the rioters
and they're going to cut to the 15
seconds that if you just don't see what
happened right before and right after
you'll take this to be the police
aggressing
against the rioters and the fact is the
other story is right there ready to be
reported
but what i don't see is the national
press
anywhere no well you know it that's
interesting i didn't see much national
press uh when i was in the ground either
in the fed in front of the federal
building or when i was going out last
week with them on the ground
um you know there's a lot of news going
on in the country obviously uh
portland is a story um but a lot of
people i think
are you know just relying on you know
grabbing these clips from online and
and most of it will grab the narrative
that it's like you know the
the evil feds and the evil police and
then of course
unfortunately you have on the other side
which they just grabbed the
the absolutely worst thing that some
protesters or
demonstrated i'm calling them
demonstrators now because if you call
them protesters people are like
are you kidding you're gonna still run
with that line and if you call them
rioters then you get
they're just out there peaceful
protesting so i'm settling on
demonstrators right now
i want to come back to that but i
finished your life and i want to okay
i'm just saying you've got the other
side of the press that goes too far
i think sometimes which is like savage
is coming to your city
and it's like okay guys you know the
story you have this on our side like
the story's in the middle to them for
the most part
so that's that's been the story i've
been trying to tell it anyway
demonstrators go for it
well first of all i'm not so sure the
story is in the middle
um okay the story is not the version
that either of the two now discontinuous
elements of the press are reporting so i
guess maybe technically it's between
them
but well maybe the best way in here is
the question of
what we call this phenomenon and my
feeling is
and frankly i faced this all the way
back in 2017
right i find the world is now catching
up to the question of
whether you call them protesters or
writers is
essential and what i've been saying very
clumsily for all of these
years is i call the thing that showed up
in my classroom
you know at 10 in the morning on may
23rd
uh that was a protest and i say it
quickly devolved into riots which it did
they were barricading buildings they
were kidnapping
uh members of the administration they
assaulted people
they had the police stood down and then
they wandered the campus
with weapons um so the point is
protest and riot both have a relevance
but it's actually a temporal shift
is what happened and the same thing
happens here in portland with a twist
which is there is a protest
that happens every night and it
predictably turns into a riot and so in
a sense
this isn't even the situation in
that happened at evergreen where things
plausibly escalated
this is actually a plan and in some
sense the
protest is there to be captured for
those who are reporting to an audience
that wants to hear
that portland is finally standing up
against police brutality
and that the feds are coming in to you
know to
institute some kind of fascist thing and
they've been repelled by the protesters
who valiantly
confronted them or something like that
if you're you know msnbc
then the point is you know what time to
show up to see
a protest that's a protest but if you
are engaged in a protest that you know
for sure
is going to become a riot later in the
evening you're actually signing up for
responsibility
for that right that's my opinion so i'm
going to walk back a little bit
of what i said in terms of the stories
in the middle i think the story is
all over i think that all of these
things can be true at the same time
and i'm going to agree with you that say
yes you know
because there were people that are sort
of in the middle i mean there really
were people that are like i
really want to do something to try to
make it better
so you know black men are not killed i
mean they really are trying but they're
not the people really around anymore and
i i actually don't think i mean
not from what i've seen i was in
portland all last week for about a week
and a half
the the sort of more peaceful protest
they've really died down
you really don't see those anymore those
people are not marching
anymore in front of the building i did
see a nice um
cavalcade of cars one night going
through northeast portland that was
super peaceful you know they're
kind of with flags and tuning and you
know they're part of the community too
but all of that is sort of now receded
what we have consistently every now
every day now
except not last night weirdly and
there's some questions about why that
was
uh is we have
the uh black bloc which is the sort of
you know
antifa s arm that believes in you know
you know by any method including
violence um
and we've got some black lives matter
protesters we've got some
randos uh we've got some hot heads we've
got some people that are confused
um and they do have a plan and i know
that
because i uh i have been speaking with
several of them
but they're not supposed to talk to you
but they do sometimes because people
need to tell you their story
and they definitely do have a plan and
their plan
is basically to get the populace
of portland to mistrust the police
enough that it's not just a matter maybe
of defunding
it's a matter of the police are not
going to be people that you're going to
call because you don't trust them
anymore and
also because they can't respond
right yep portland is already down
i think it's about 500 officers than
they should be
and then they've got people that are
retiring early because who the heck
wants to be a portland police officer in
portland
right now or they're just resigning and
getting the hell out of there and doing
something else
um so you're down 500 officers right and
then you can't treat you can't replace
them like you can't replace them fast
enough
especially especially if you're
defunding because the obvious way to
replace
police officers who are fleeing in
droves is to
uh make it a more attractive job
effectively pay them for hazard pay so
you're cutting the police at the same
point you're demonizing them which is
going to result in fewer
worse police and it's going to increase
the brutality because
the point is the brutality is a
substitute for
resources so now we had that horrible
incident
about a week and a half ago when that
guy was pulled out of his car
and you know beaten downtown and
i was out i think it was the following
night or two nights later and i was
hanging out with some black bloc
kids it was an interesting piece it's up
on reason uh
and this one kid who i don't know if he
mistook me for one of his like press
people or if he just wanted to talk
but he did and i said to him so listen i
know that you know
antifa doesn't you know reign in anybody
else everybody do their own thing
different groups you might not be in
charge of this
what do what do they think about what
happened downtown that guy getting
beaten and he said to me
you know what the cops know who those
kids are those are the 7-eleven kids
and they should have been there and i
was like yeah but they're chasing you
all around town
right and he kind of looked at his shoes
and with a not very anarchistic
sensibility said yeah but they should
have been there but how can they be
there
i mean someone told me the other day
their car got stolen and they called the
cops the cops are like sorry
nothing we could do about it and if they
had been there
there is no question in my mind that it
would have been
filmed and portrayed as
an abuse of power so
right it's an opportunity it's an
opportunity uh
to make the police look bad at every
turn
and um this is very deliberate this is
you know
being built right now narratively with
people's iphones
that's that's what's happening it is the
construction of a false narrative
over things that kind of happened sort
of happened
right you can piece together a very
false story
out of things you know out of edits
basically the editor
is you know the editor rules the
narrative in the video age
and the problem is
i mean first of all this black bloc
thing
goes on all the time in the pacific
northwest
it's a feature of the landscape right
and it is
larping i believe but um
the idea that a
confused general outpouring of
anger and support after george floyd's
death
has now largely dried up and something
else has taken up the mantle but it was
doing its thing before this
right it wasn't absolutely it was about
tearing down civilization
from the beginning it's been demonizing
cops since
you know occupying before right and the
point is it's just continuing to do its
thing
but now it has the attention of the
world and it has this
cloak that it is using which has to do
with
um protecting black people and improving
the quality of their lives
and it's unassailable right because if
you complain about it if you say guys
like why don't we sit at the table and
talk about this then it's like well
you're a racist it's like well i'm
not actually not like that's that you
know they feel that
whatever they're doing now they have
exact cloak is exactly right
whatever they're going to say is is
unassailable i'll tell you one more just
think just to get back to the editing
and then we'll
we'll we'll move on the first night i
was in portland last
month uh they were the federal building
stuff was really in high gear
and um they attacked the building for
about
three hours uh setting fires trash
burning barbecues this and that knocking
down fences
and um they actually then they you know
got in
and and were tearing off the plywood and
smashing it down with a fire
extinguisher something i filmed by the
way and when to show you what people
want to see when i put it online
somebody commented oh i can tell nancy
rommelman staged that in a studio
because you know
you can see the shininess on it i'm like
what are you talking about
but anyway it was about three hours into
that
before the feds shot out their first
tear gas
and everybody you know kind of ran away
once and they're pretty organized walked
on run walk don't run so people don't
get you know
uh stampeded and then you get into the
park and the girls can i wash your eyes
like they've got a little
pattern going but everybody was saying i
can't believe they tear gassed us i'm
like
guys you're setting fire to the building
for three
hours like do you you know you want
provocation you know you want it
so bad you want them to respond to you
so they did so stop complaining right no
the whole point is to provoke the
response and film the response in
absolutely started at the best moment to
create the false story
now the other thing that you just said
here in passing is so
important i've seen this a hundred times
now where okay
you have a really inconvenient video for
their narrative right right now it's not
hard to catch an
inconvenient video of their narrative
because they're constantly
doing things to provoke and if you catch
the provocation
then the whole thing is over so what
happens well
they will demonize you they will
demonize your publication
and if all else fails they will just
flat out lie about the nature of
whatever it is
you have produced and the point is it is
not
going to i call it implausible
deniability
and the idea is it's constructed for
people
who want something to say and the point
is it doesn't matter how low grade it is
they'll give you the best thing they can
give you to dismiss anything you want to
dismiss
right up you know through a lie if they
have to and the point is if you're msnbc
and you're trying to construct a story
of peaceful protesters
who are being attacked by trump's feds
yadda yadda
then you just go through the thing and
basically the point is you have an
excuse for everything you don't want to
report
and then you have a list of things that
you want to amplify and you've created
total fiction out of a kind of
pre-rationalized editable content
and we can't live this way the fact is
to be
an entity uh of the press to be
journalistic
you have to report things that are not
consistent with the overarching story
you're telling
when they happen and in this case um if
you don't do that what you get is a
totally phony story
right a totally funny story that's very
compelling because
it's made of video you can't can't walk
in with your uh
with your your your end like knowing oh
i know how the story's gonna
you gotta let the story tell itself to
you i think two things i think it's ex
i i i not only think it's extremely
irresponsible
for any news organization or any entity
at all to not report what they see to
you know to trim the facts to fit the
theory
i think it's extremely dangerous i i i
know it's extremely dangerous
and it's equally dangerous to to pacify
the story
to play down what's happening it's like
and i
you know you get this has sort of been a
little like an insider baseball thing
lately it's like what's the journalist
responsibility
is it to you know fight power is it to
speak truth to power the journalist's
responsibility
is to report what you see okay yeah
we're all gonna have our little blinders
i get it i get it you know
but you should and that is something
that i think has been in short supply
in portland in my experience oh it's
been
it's been absent the danger couldn't be
greater i mean and i say this is
somebody who's
now living in portland i'm watching the
police
dwindle i'm watching them hamstrung
i'm watching them fatigue i mean they
are literally being attacked
up in seattle you know it's a different
version of the same phenomenon
we had an incident where um quick drying
cement of some kind was used to attempt
to lock police into a building that was
being set on fire
um that's it
i mean that's attempted murder right now
i don't know if this was symbolic or if
they really thought the door was going
to seal but
i want people to think about what it is
like to have a group of people
demonizing the police as all cops are
bastards
as they are actually contemplating
simulating
hinting at uh suggesting murder of
police
right and demonstrating that actually
you know what
they were in the commercial district
they were attacking government buildings
they're now in neighborhoods they are
now revealing
that they view the populace of portland
as the enemy
and the fact is there's no
way out based on courageous leadership
our leadership our civilian leadership
in portland is absolutely out to lunch
it has been coddling this it has created
the phenomenon and there's no
alternative of people who are just
even sensible so where does this go
so a couple of things in terms of what
they're doing to the police i know
they're throwing these sort of um
you know balloons now or paint balloons
that have um
grit in it so it'll actually like damage
the helmet or damage or windshield so
you can't even like
uh you can't even clean yourself off to
see what you need to do
they also do things that that are so i
mean you realize sometimes how young
these people are
they they they now throw like feces i
i was there one night and the the cop
was airing out the lobby of the police
station because they came in through a
bucket of
species and diarrhea i'm like so they
actually did that like they all
[ __ ] in a bucket like like this is like
incredible
you know that this is what you would
think is the way we're going to change
the world is we're all going to poop in
a bucket
it's mental patient stuff and to do it
in the middle of a pandemic yes
wow well you know they're invincible
because they're 20. but um one thing i
did want to mention
i was speaking with someone uh who had
knew a lot about black bloc and she was
saying
that because the optics are so important
um they actually don't want to kill
anybody like they set the the cop shop
the
um gesture center on fire may 29th i
wrote a story about a woman that was
works there's trapped in the basement
you talk about rubber cementing someone
in um
they actually know that killing someone
is going to be bad optics so they're
going to keep that but here's my
contention
and i've written about this this
movement has a glow
right and it glows and it glows and it
glows what people are attracted to glow
it's not always going to be someone
that's in your little black block
affinity group
it's going to be mr bonehead over here
that is going to be a hero
or going to like just take it to the
next level you have no control over that
right right
oh so i don't accept this uh they know
for exactly the reason you just pointed
out some of them know
right but the very nature of this thing
the cellular nature of black bloc
and their central dogma
involves this euphemistically named
diversity of tactics thing
and the point is diversity of tactics
means
essentially look um we're going to have
some
timid people they're going to do some
protest stuff that'll be good for the
optics we're going to have some violent
people they're going to do some
thuggery right and you know innovate
something
and the point is look you're telling
people
that it's a diversity of tactics you're
spray-painting the wall
with the suggestion that police deserve
to be murdered
right if somebody takes your goddamn
suggestion
right that's on you you set this up and
the fact that you
didn't really mean it is nothing right
but
they'll never but they'll never ever
accept that
right so okay joe bonehead goes and he
kills two cops
right but who's gonna take
responsibility for that
why do we care what they accept
they are in violation of the law they
are
proposing things that are inconsistent
with the continuing of society
we have every right to shut this down
and you know what it's going to look
like when it gets shut down
it's going to be ugly so be it that's
the nature of it well
we've i've talked about this before you
and i i think even talked about this
it's like
what how elastic is the term
peaceful protest right because you know
i saw arie welsher
standing in front of a raging fire and i
think it was kenosha two days ago
i mean it was not just like a little
fire it was a raging
fire and and the words that came out and
i like this guy came out of his mouth
was
well you know it's mostly been a
peaceful protest i'm like wow
so so what okay
you you the people in portland are now
across the country in cities peaceful
protest now also means
the destruction of property it means
waking up citizens
it means throwing feces in the police
station all of this
in portland now because of what our or
the d.a there has done
not prosecuting a lot of these crimes
against the these are now considered
that's peaceful protest it's not
well but the thing is um on the one hand
i watched you know the intelligentsia of
twitter
finally get its act together on this
point the way it finally got its act
together
on the difference between a protest and
a riot a couple weeks ago
um yesterday or the day before suddenly
i started seeing the right discussion
about peaceful protest but wow are we
late to this party
right this is not a peaceful protest
this is
the uninvention of the distinction
between
assault and battery right if you have a
bunch of people
marching you know raising their fists in
the air
who know that there's going to be an
attack there's going to be
you know arson an attack on a federal
building
there's going to be projectiles launched
at officers
they are involved in the equivalent of
assault the battery begins at the point
that it becomes physical but the
protest is a threat of that thing that
comes later and so um
on the i don't want to pat us on the
back for finally discovering that
peaceful protest is an insane concept
um because we shouldn't have taken so
long to articulate this this was obvious
from the get-go as soon as we had a
pattern where every night
you had a march and then violence
the point is okay everybody who's
marching knows the violence comes later
well i think we started out talking
about why this can happen in portland
and you've got a lot of people in
portland who again
they're just sort of you know they they
want to identify with these progressive
values maybe they dreamt of being a
little more radical when they were in
college 20 years ago or something
though last night for the last trip i
was there i was down at the federal
building
they were the feds were still inside and
it had grown from 150
like kind of ratty kids smacking stuff
around to 2000 people with
vendors and a really really nice
laser light show against the building as
i've said before not built by your kid
in her
bedroom okay this was i'm not saying it
was nike but it's like my mind it was
like oh you know who did that
it was someone who's not going to
actually come out at night
and protest but it's someone like going
hey i support these kids
i support like you know changing our
society so i'm gonna do what i can
they've got i know in june there was a
500 000
bail fund set up for kids who got
arrested i covered the
the fire in kenton when these these
protesters got like you know they were
setting the police building on fire
the police kettled them away they ran
through kenton which
two days before had just built this
lovely plaza to help
businesses because of ovid they set it
all on fire
the next day they had a check for 2500
from the protesters
i said to the head of the business
association i'm like he's like yeah i
don't think it was the same kids
that set fire you know there are people
looking
out for for this
and supporting it behind the scenes in
whether it's just
emotionally financially creatively
i defensively oh definitely because also
they you know
they don't want to ever have anybody
else be right about their city you know
and the trump hatred is so thick and so
deep
um but i have a question for you
now that we see nightly uh and it has
been nightly though last night
apparently was
quiet in portland which is the first
time in 93 nights
um if if neighborhood blocks are being
walked down and the kids are shouting
get up get up get up [ __ ] get up
and shouting in people's faces
i mean it doesn't matter you could be in
there with your husband dying of cancer
or your four kids or your mother with
alzheimer's doesn't matter
they don't care do you think there's a
point
where people are gonna like go from just
being either
actively supportive too quietly
supportive
to afraid to then maybe getting over
their fear and saying
no more uh absolutely
um now it's not going to be everybody
some people will
bend over backwards in order to you know
be more supportive because of their fear
right that's the problem is that the
game theory actually does result in a
certain number of people
becoming monsters themselves in order
not to be the target of this thing
that's that's why they do it this way
and then a lot of people are going to be
quietly
willing to do uh something to oppose
this
or at least rooting for something to
oppose it
now the problem is apparently
our mayor is so dumb that he doesn't
understand
that there are a great many people who
do not feel safe saying
they would support an aggressive hand in
doing away with the nightly violence
but quietly that's what they want
right if if every neighborhood is on the
map of
places that the black bloc is going to
come and harass people
then you can imagine there are an awful
lot of people living in those
neighborhoods
rooting for something to stop it but
mayor wheeler
only sees that which is said out loud
and in a culture of fear like this you
know what's said out loud
you know this that's what's said out
loud
yeah exactly and even though people may
feel that way and i have some people
sort of feeding me that
like uh like i'm asking my neighbors do
you feel this way yet
last week they're like no no no go kids
go and this week it's kind of like
no i i but who's going to actuate it
who's going to actuate this change it's
not going to be the city council
the city council who are so completely
pro
pro this sort of progressivism whether
they admit it or not
they are supporting this and have been
supporting this by all of the laws that
they keep passing
to you know give the give the police
less power to make sure the feds don't
come back
to make sure things aren't prosecutable
anymore so who's going to actuate it
uh no it's going to be a catastrophe and
you know what
the fact is that catastrophe is going to
result
in my opinion very likely in a landslide
for bush
i mean bush what am i talking about
we'd be happy with the landslides right
now it's going to be a landslide for
trump
because silently all the people who know
that this goes
nowhere are going to end up holding
their nose and voting for him
and um you know then what
then you've got a guy who doesn't have
to be reelected
who um has nothing to gain by
treating this movement with kid gloves
and will be a hero to
his base for i mean it's just gonna be a
disaster
it's very interesting because i i i find
it so shocking the idea that like just
about any portlander would vote for
trump
i do think you know we've got an openly
antifa
uh mayoral candidate a woman named sarah
iannaroni
uh and she's the only one that has any
kind of chance against
wheeler who i don't know that people can
vote
hate him any more than they do however i
wonder
if people will just secretly vote for
him anyway just because they're
they're so terrified of going with a
with an antifa
candidate though there is the
possibility and i'm toying with writing
about this that uh antifa actually goes
main street
in portland like this is the place where
it happens
what would that look like well that that
would be
um that would be enough of success if
you
actually had i mean antifa is apparently
i'm not an expert
on it but it's pretty decentralized uh
but there are
things that they want to get done
including defunding the police uh
and if you can get the police weak
enough i don't think you'll
defund it all the way but it will be
sort of like only for people that are
willing to be law abiding
then you you you um you you
vote in this sarah iannaroni who is
openly pro-antifa
right now antifa doesn't have a
figurehead
deliberately you still haven't told me
hold on hold on okay
so you now have a figurehead in in uh
iannaroni
right but is she the one that's like
pulling the levers
i don't know does she i i don't know but
if she's in power
and she's pro-antifa what happens to the
sort of systems
and the structures of of of policing and
stuff we have
in the we have in the city
it collapses right so i've been told
uh though they would never call
themselves this that you know
antifa is ready to step in and police
well but we've seen this
i i lived it okay i i was hunted in my
own neighborhood at evergreen when the
when the president of the college stood
the police down
right so i lived it we don't have to do
that
in portland in order to figure out how
it works if you had any doubt that what
happened
in olympia was representative
we know from seattle's autonomous zone
that the same thing
happened there we know that it's
happened here in portland with the
undeclared autonomous zone in front of
the federal building
so it's not a secret what happens when
you allow
this uh euphemistically called community
policing to step in for regular policing
what it turns into
is uh thuggery that is wielded against
people that the community police view as
their antagonists
and anybody who sees things differently
um
and um you know it's gonna result in
murder
and mayhem and warlordism well this is
one thing
you know i i've written several times is
that
um right now in portland
uh and in other places i think across
the country they're very very good at
tearing things down
young lots of energy it's easy to set a
fire
it's easy to do all of these things i
have no
no evidence yet zero that they know how
to build anything
we know they don't because they keep
telling us what they think is true and
it's wrong for such obvious reasons
right the idea that you are going to
help black people
by reducing the level of policing
is insane on its face right
you can't do this the idea that a
colorblind society is not something we
should desire we should be interested
in race first no
that's nonsense that is going to result
in a
breakdown in civil order that is going
to fall most heavily on the people
who are claimed to be helped by that
perspective this can't work they're
telling us they don't know the first
thing about how things actually function
if they frankly they can't run a rib
shop
right yeah a city i don't think they're
gonna run a city
so someone asked me the other day
they're like because i was i was mostly
in the city
part of portland and they said well
where is this happening it's like it's
mostly like middle class sections of
portland um but our friend uh matt welch
who has
his family is originally from portland
he's like nancy
what the hell is going on in gresham
okay
gresham is right outside of portland i
had to know if you call it a bedroom
community
a little bit of a of a suburb now
they're
having their own issues there but what
do you have there
you have more of a sort of
proud boys contingent willing to come
out
and uh and uh mix it up
so what what have you seen about about
gresham that was two days ago
i've seen very little um it's possible
i've been preoccupied by
uh events over in unity 2020 land but
um but in any case what do you know
about uh
well they were you know basically
shouting
in each other's faces in gresham uh
apparently there's also
sort of people building funds out there
to protect
the sort of progressive element it's
moving a little bit into the suburbs and
that's a little bit surprising you know
someone also asked me like well nancy
why do all these things happen in like
portland and seattle like why not you
know i don't know
um pocatello it's like well
because the kids that wanted to like
live these ideals and these dreams were
drawn to other people like them
right gresham is not exactly where you'd
think you'd have
black block cells but you do
yeah um okay so
this is not a very heartening
conversation unfortunately
because i you know you're telling me uh
very much what it it seems like when i i
do the calculations myself which is that
we
are involved in a slow motion train
wreck and that slow motion train wreck
is the result of a very obvious story
that would be very easy to report if
only there were a journalistic
outfit interested in doing so
unfortunately the only journalistic
outfit
interested in doing so is reason
magazine
no look i appreciate what you're doing
and frankly you know you're taking a
risk on all of our behalf
because you're recognizable and um
that actually is getting to be a little
bit of a problem it really wasn't
before but my last story there uh
i had someone uh very directly i mean i
i had been at the um
i had been at the rally 90 seconds and i
was told i was gonna get my ass kicked
quite loudly and uh saw the guy banging
around with stick later he was arrested
two days later i had a guy come up to me
and it's like we know who you are you
know
and i was like okay i'm still writing
about you but here
here's the thing this is actually
i don't want to say it's the key because
there are many keys but
you can't have a society that functions
if certain people
are unsafe if you could go to the
protest because
you weren't recognizable two months ago
but you can't now because of who you are
because you did go
because you reported because you did so
honestly
if i can't go because
i'm not having any of this you know the
world belongs to the editor
[ __ ] then what does that tell you a
citizen
some citizens of portland could go to
this mostly peaceful protest
and other citizens of portland can't
what the hell is that i think you
i feel very comfortable in just telling
them
no i'm not leaving and i will tell you
and it's in one of the stories
unreason i was out one night and this
young
girl i don't know late 20s all black
blocked
went up to a woman who was standing on
the sidewalk about 50 year old woman
and said you're not allowed to film and
the woman said
excuse me i live on this block i do
anything i want the girls like
you're not allowed to film and that
woman got right in her face and she said
you are not going to tell me what to do
and by the way your mother did not raise
you this way
and this girl she crumpled
i watched her crumple and but hold on so
she goes back to her little
you know her little magic outfit didn't
protect her
and the woman came up to me and said
she's latina like me and i'm telling you
her parents and grandparents did not
raise her this way now
this is one little lady in in canton
well what if most of the population says
that you know there are more people in
portland than there are black blockers
by far by far i mean
a hundred to one a thousand to one
people just have to say no
i get to do whatever the hell i want to
do on my block sorry
problem is the
people of portland are having their
empathy weaponized against them
their desire to do the right thing
with respect to um the situation that
black americans find themselves in and i
believe that there is a situation and
that it does
require redress but that
desire to be on the right side of that
issue is being
cynically used by the black bloc antifa
contention
and it is going to result in people not
standing up but nonetheless
i i agree that
you and i could go anywhere in portland
and 95 of the people we interacted with
no matter how
troubled they are by either one of us
would leave us
alone that does not mean it's the same
problem as the crazy person who doesn't
understand
that the graffiti invitations to murder
that are spray painted
all over the walls of downtown are
not to be taken literally i don't think
either one of us would be safe down
there because of the five percent
that isn't in on that part or the five
percent that says
that the people who think that that's
symbolic are
wrong and the important thing that we do
is
commit violence against people who are
describing the other narrative
and they want to be a hero i mean there
was a kid there was a kid that was
arrested i guess about a week and a half
ago he was the one that went
to a rally with a gun and he put on he
fired off a couple of shots and he was
arrested
and i threw the grapevine i heard he's
um
he was i guess he'd been in the military
and he's like a deeply
troubled really swayable
kid who you know found a place to be
whether i don't know what particular
anti-black block group it was but he
decided he was going to be like the good
guy and go out and do this
and uh yeah he's the person that you
have to be where it's always the
it's sort of the the quiet one you
wouldn't suspect
that you you have to be a little bit
worried about maybe not the kid that's
just screaming in your face
right but we can't very well have a city
in which um
people's political understanding of the
world i don't even want to say it's a
political perspective my feeling is i'm
interested in the real story
um as you are the interest in the real
story
makes us i believe demonstrably less
safe
in portland and you can't have a city
that functions that way the fact is
a city has to be indifferent to what you
think is true
that's one of the foundational
principles of
this nation and um we are descending
into
a situation where not only is race going
from something
where uh we aspired to a society in
which it didn't matter we're
headed the other direction where it
matters more than anything else but
we are moving from a society in which
you're free to
think and say anything to one in which
what you think and say
dictates your your quality of life and
your safety and
uh to say that that is unsustainable
is just you know uh it is the very
beginning of what it is it's the
beginning of
madness do people start leaving
because i've heard some people are of
course yeah
they came you know they came to portland
about
a little before i got the people started
coming to
to live their achievable dreams right
um justice uh you know
gay marriage things that they really
just really meant a lot to them a clean
place to raise their kids it was
affordable
um it's becoming a place that's not
that's not like that it's an
it's becoming an unsafe place and i
don't really know
many people that want to live
with physical insecurity i mean
to not know whether it will be my block
tonight
that they're i mean it's just the idea
that it could be you're never
comfortable
in your own city on your own street in
your own home
and that's a problem the thing is it
escalates
so it escalated from the commercial and
government district
to neighborhoods it escalates from
burning a trash can in the street to
trying to burn down
buildings associated with the police
will it escalate from shining incredibly
bright lights and shouting harassing
things
into the windows of neighborhoods
to attempting to burn down houses in
neighborhoods
if they can justify seriously we are
allowing something to escalate
that clearly does not agree
that citizens are entitled to be safe
it is trying to create a level of
unsafety for everyone
and why it would do something so the
thing is that
you really don't like whether that is
dumb i think one thing i wish people
would
are you there and you hear me
i i can hear you just fine
i hear you now okay yeah we had a little
glitch there um
oh my internet connection is unstable i
don't know why
um i think people have to become a
little less afraid of being accused of
being a racist
because that's become something that
everybody is so terrified of that they
you know put the sign in the window put
it in the window quick
you know but they don't they don't need
to actually
be a racist they don't need you to have
done anything
if they decide that you're the person
based on a lie based on a whim
based on you know which way the wind is
blowing sure
maybe it'll burn down your house again
that's the definition of peaceful
protest
it has just grown the band grows a
little wider a little wider a little
wider
and they justify it in their mind why
you were a racist
well no i wasn't well too bad
done now we're at that next level yeah i
you know i i don't know what to even
make of that because
the um the thing that brought me to
public attention was obviously
the fact that i said nope i'm not a
racist
and all hell broke loose and i certainly
survived it
and uh the world looked into my
background i'm sure if it had found the
slightest hint of racism it would have
you know uh with delight marched me into
the public square and
you know uh humiliated me it didn't find
it and so
the point is actually it is
survivable if you say nope um
and especially if people do it um
in numbers right doing it alone means
you're going to be heavily scrutinized
but if a bunch of people say no
that formulation is nonsense lots of
people aren't racist
um and we are among them then we would
begin to turn the tide but for some
reason
you're right the terror of being accused
is so great that people just simply
won't do it
there's also something else happening in
portland that someone wrote me a really
interesting email about which was you
know you had a lot of new
newcomers to portland in the past 20
years or so and they came here with
similar ideals but from
you know different parts of the country
they settle on a block they don't really
know their neighbors that well maybe you
might know them but you don't
you don't have that like history you
might have had
they're obviously very you know um
anti-gun for the most part in
in portland proper uh and so when these
people come on their block
and start you know terrorizing them in
the middle of the night
um though i was told today oh nancy come
on that's not terror
that's free speech i'm like yeah okay so
i'd like you to go and look at the early
struggle sessions and the cultural
revolution just like
rise yourself a little bit but okay so
you're on the block now
and you've got i don't know 100 kids
that come in here and they're screaming
well if everybody came out onto their
front porches and said
hey guys get the off my block but
they're not going to because they
don't have the confidence and the
connection to their neighbors
so we don't have there's not that
cohesion yet where i think portlanders
can stand up you know besides the fear
besides the silent support whatever just
even if you want to do it who's going to
do it with me
yep i i uh agree and i hope we will see
that maybe it's already happening and we
don't know about it because it wouldn't
be public but
i agree people need to talk to their
neighbors they need to meet them
now um as for people being anti-gun
i think that ship has sailed do you
think so i've heard that
gun sales are up everywhere uh app
doesn't begin to describe
up does not begin to describe it and um
you apparently this is not
gun enthusiasts buying more guns
this is people who have not had guns
buying them for the first time
which is dangerous in and of itself
right yes it is people don't know what
the hell they're doing
yeah and but they're see and and also
when people are scared
they make terrible decisions okay i mean
this is just
a disaster this is a disaster waiting to
happen
and it's going to happen i interviewed
someone the other day
and he said it is a testament to the
passivity of portlanders
that no one has been shot yet in in like
on these streets because you know if you
were in like upstate new york where my
mother lives
her her her neighbors they're both
prison guards
be over in one night well
but i'm exaggerating no it's
exaggerating but
there is something interesting there is
a restraint that has been shown
nationwide so far and the problem is we
are all depending on that restraint
holding and something restoring reason
before it breaks because it will break
at some point
but but brett nationwide in the cities
besides kenosha which is a
bit of a outlier uh where it's happening
you have
it's the same sort of populace as
portland in some respects and it's the
same sort of news reporting okay
they're not doing this again in
pocatello right
if they were i don't think we'd seen and
i i'm sorry i don't even know anything
about pocatello i'm just using it
because it's alliterative with portland
right
so it's in idaho but but i don't think
we would have seen 93 nights
in pocatello right well
maybe i'm wrong unfortunately
the restraint i believe has a lot to do
with an analogous kind of game theory to
the one that creates
looting and rioting right so
basically we hire
collectively we don't want to spend more
money on policing than is necessary
so we spend enough money to keep things
more or less lawful during normal
circumstances and then every so often
something will call the attention of a
great many
police so that the right number of
police is suddenly too
low and you get looting because people
realize the law is not being enforced
and this is their opportunity
so my point would be
until mayhem has broken out the
risk to people for taking the law into
their own hands
is sufficient to keep them from doing it
at the point it becomes commonplace
then it's going to skyrocket and so
my plea to our fellow countrymen
is we have to get a handle on this
before
that happens all hell is going to break
loose it's not going to be as slow
ratcheting up
it's going to become suddenly much more
common
and at that point it becomes much harder
to address
it's going to be very hard to put the
toothpaste back in the tube that's right
it's like bankruptcy it happens slowly
and then all at once or or
pain like when you're when you've had an
operation they're like stay ahead of the
pain take that painkiller now
because once you're in pain then you
gotta let just suffer
so yeah i would say and i i would agree
with you like
get to know your neighbors decide like
do you want this happening
on your block and if you don't then talk
back to these because
brett i have seen these kids crumple so
many times when it's one-on-one and i'll
tell you another thing which
people don't want to hear but it is my
responsibility as a journalist to report
this
most of these kids that i have talked to
one-on-one
are extremely polite do you want some
water can i get you a donut
how are you this and that it's like and
this is not that
they're like oh i'm gonna put on the
nice little act or the
journalist like they're kids
but you get them together and they are
gonna
get that collective effervescence and
they're gonna get the slogan earring
and it's a horror show but one on one if
you talk to these kids
i don't know just to be friendly to be
nice to whatever you want some roast
beef
or just to say no they crumple
i i agree with you and um you know
lord of the flies was one of the
analogies that kept cropping up
when evergreen happened and it was the
same damn thing which is that this
you know good kids hanging out with the
wrong crowd
turn into bad kids that's what's going
on so somehow
you know i s on the right i see a lot of
demonizing
of the individuals involved in this but
it's not the individual
it's the de-individuation that is so
dangerous and
you know it's not it's not unsolvable
but you do
have to say no and you know you have the
same thing
uh you know you demonize like the proud
boys or patriot prayer and you know i
certainly get it in the media these are
not
people that are are very popular but
i've also met
a lot of these guys one-on-one and they
are you know
one rinsed my eyes the other day right
and he was a can i help you is like
super gentlemanly
now that's going to be super unpopular
to say but
hello all those people ready to you know
say i'm a proud boy supporter i just
said the same thing about the black
pockets
because we all put on our pants one leg
at a time okay
yes there are bad apples yes when they
get together things can be terrible
but individually they're mostly just
young people
yep i agree and they're responding to
the the situation they find themselves
in so all right you've said something
unpopular about
the proud boys containing human beings
yeah now it's my turn sure so
uh when i first moved to portland i um
there was a one of these announced
rallies by
the proud boys and patriot prayer and
antifa announced they were going to have
a counter
demonstration and andy noah suggested
that i
go and check it out which i thought was
a good idea so i did
and i spent some time on the
antifa black block side and i spent some
time on the proud boys
patriot prayer site just i wanted to see
the difference and
the cultural difference was spectacular
yes i've done
exactly the same thing as you um first
of all antifa demonized me because
you know they could edit it to oh he was
over hanging out with the proud boys
when the fact
is i actually spent more time on the
antifa side where things were much
nastier and
on the proud boys uh patriot prayer side
things were more welcoming weirdly
and including there was a couple of
trans
people who were absolutely part of the
milieu
you know a surprising number actually
i've noticed that too and the proud boys
a surprising number of trans people
i noticed that the other day i was like
wow that's interesting and they're not
they're not being tolerated for show
they seem to be fully
integrated into the to the culture
people just people exactly
um but here was the the weird story so i
was standing there
observing the speeches on the uh
the proud boys side and a guy approaches
me
i didn't know if he was proud boys or uh
patriot prayer or
something else and he says are you brett
weinstein
and i said yeah and he introduced
himself
and anyway we got to talking and i was
trying to you know he was curious about
my perspective on things and i was
telling him where i was coming from and
all
and uh he said you know i i wasn't
i wasn't always you know so far to the
right in fact i voted for
obama twice and i looked at him and i
said
you know i only could vote for him once
i was so troubled by what happened in
the first one and he
burst into laughter he's like i'm more
liberal than brett weinstein right um
so anyway we had this moment where
hey i realized something which is he
even saw in himself that there had been
he had been on board with a much
different view
of the nation and had lost confidence in
it
um and has now now finds himself over
with the proud boys um but
uh you know there was a recognition that
we're sort of
all in you know i haven't moved at all
politically i'm still
very much uh on the left but there was
no
animosity there was no concern
it was just it was very much more
the expectation that we differ in our
perspectives and that it doesn't mean
um we can't talk so anyway
it was a an odd discovery let's put it
that way
that's my exact experience too i i went
to a rally
i don't know if it was the same one it
was last uh not this past
not this month august uh august 2019 and
i did the exact same thing i spent time
on the antifa side i spent time in like
the
keep portland weird side which was
hilarious i talked to some
john brown gun people i spent time with
the patriot prayer and the proud boys
and um the only place that i felt
unsafe was
with a line of uh black block
kids that were all sort of really
identically dressed
with uh not with shields but with
umbrellas and one kid had black
uh brass knuckles and he he did that
to me and i wa and it wasn't that that
made me feel unsafe but we were
underneath the bridge and there were
about 600 of them screaming at the same
time and i was like
okay that's about enough of this um
but otherwise you talk to them again
one-on-one when they're willing
you know they want to stay masked a lot
of the time and i you know
it gives them their you know their
secret superpower strength to not
uh be tender right yeah
yeah to not be human it uh right frees
them from the normal stuff that would
otherwise
uh overtake them so
um this the problem is that evergreen i
saw this
close up and the fact is it was
possible to reach people individually
this is before masks of course
but you could reach people individually
but what happened
every time was that anybody you reached
was then targeted by the mob and
recaptured
and so it's this de-individuation thing
where anybody who discovers hey maybe
the world isn't
what i was thinking it was yesterday
maybe the people on the other side have
a point
right that is um
ephemeral whatever recognition they had
gets punished and they go right back
into behaving as a as a mob well you
called it out group in group out group
i mean we both know that um when someone
comes to your defense uh they are then
the next ones that are attacked
and that's why people don't do it you
know because they're afraid and we both
get that
like it's not fun to be you know the
person that's you know under attack by
hundreds or thousands of people uh but
yeah
or i remember um um heather your
your lovely wife saying to me one time
that you know some people support you
a few people will support you privately
no
a few privately publicly a few more
privately
most people sit on a fence and wait to
see which way the wind was
yes and then they're the ones who turn
on you which yeah they turn on you and
and wow really vociferously too it's
like
whoa look at her go
exactly well you know i i yeah
they have to live with themselves that's
what i think so i don't know how they do
it but i
don't either i don't either so yeah but
you can't live in fear of uh
the weakest people uh
turning on you in order to solve some
problem of theirs no that would be a sad
place to live
yeah so yeah all right well this has
been
uh very eye-opening is there anything
else you think we should say with
respect to portland or the larger
context
i would be interested um only because it
was i'm here in new york city right now
where i live i'll probably be coming
back because this story is evolving
uh it was a quiet night last night and
that
is unusual uh some people suggested it
was because maybe you know some of them
went to dc for the rnc and i think some
did i just think people really need
to keep an eye on where this is going
and i think they really do have to say i
don't want to live this way
i don't i i don't think it's i don't
it's not going to do anything good for
our city
all right i still call it our city i
live in new york now but you know for
portland
you know what we're americans it's your
city too
um and frankly i'm uh i am
very grateful that you have taken the
time
and the the put yourself in jeopardy to
report on the story because
as much as it would be tremendously
important to have
a much larger news organization do the
job
in the absence of any major news
organization properly reporting the
portland story
having you do it has been a godsend
i am super super grateful to reason for
um
for i you know i called like emailed my
editor texted my editor one morning and
just said i want to go she said go
and they've just been super great to
report for and i will keep reporting for
them
yep you are you are doing the work of
the nation um
you know right well i mean you are
in fact portland is an important story
and everybody's getting it wrong
and i appreciate you know your
absolute and evident commitment not to
fall into
either of the pre-packaged narratives
because they're both wrong
thank you brett thank you all right okay
so
nancy um people can find you
on twitter n-a-n-c-y-r-o-m-m
nancy rom uh they can go to nancyrom.com
and see all kinds of stuff that i've
done and uh
go over to reason.com uh if you put in
my name you'll get all the stories
and um and there will be more coming and
uh
they should check out your book which is
oh yeah
a murder here in portland in portland a
woman who threw two young children off a
bridge
and uh one died one lived and it was a
story
again the narrative was told one way by
the media and i was like
nah i don't think so i don't think
that's the story so yeah that's called a
to the bridge a true story of motherhood
and murder
wonderful well thanks so much for for
joining us nancy it's been a great
conversation and i
look forward to the next one okay thanks
brett be well
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you